ça rend à la tête vers les étoiles ce
club amateur est actuellement leader de
national une équivalent de la 3e
division et espère rejoindre le monde
professionnel dès cet été et ses
résultats sportifs ne sont pas venus par
hasard on a monté un projet qui
s'appelle ambitions au projet 2015 et
donc avec la venue de fabien courtial le
nouveau coach et donc on a sollicité pas
mal de partenaires et depuis donc quatre
cinq ans on a mis en place toute une
cellule pour recruter pour évoluer pour
monter il faut se qualifier pour un
barrage seul le leader du championnat il
ya droit
là ce que veux t'assurer saran
l'adversaire du soir saint-ouen en fait
les frais les saranais déroule et même
25 à 7 à la mi temps score qui reflète
l'esprit d'équipé je pense que ce groupe
il fait preuve de deux vertus
collectives très importante qui
transpire dans leur activité défensive
par exemple et ça c'est super important
en balles notamment et est dans un sport
que vous voyez comme le nôtre une très
bonne entente un travail sur la longueur
je pense que déjà ça fait beaucoup de
choses et puis après il ya des parties
individuelles qui sont très fortes au
sein de l'équipe donc ça aide
le public ne s'y trompe pas le club
accueille jusqu'à 900 personnes les
soirs de match il soigne sa promotion et
essaie de convaincre des partenaires
financiers en cas de montée
le budget doit presque doublé pour
atteindre les huit cent cinquante mille
euros
du côté du terrain les joueurs savent ce
qui leur reste à faire
sérieux jusqu'au bout quoi est ce que
c'est ce qui nous a un peu manqué ces
quelques matchs on arrivait un petit peu
trop tranquillement c'est là on a pris
conscience qu'on est vraiment à la porte
d'un des deux donc c'est du sérieux
ça rend on a fait preuve en s'imposant
39 à 24 face à saint-ouen plus qu'une
victoire et lessard année seront assurés
de disputer les matches de barrage pour
la montée
le plus dur commence